[Musique]
vu mourir
not because bay wis
[Musique]
la roue du temps tour
et les agenais ce et meurt
[Musique]
laissant des souvenirs
destiné à devenir légende
[Musique]
quand
ce pouvoir en toi
portent différents noms à travers le
monde
mais c'est le même
le pouvoir de link
nous les femmes qui le ghana lisons
nous protégeons le monde
[Musique]
importe ce qui arrive
importe la souffrance
o le chagrin
yaro continue de tourner
le ténébreux cherche des amis
bataille
tout va dépendre de ce que tu feras
désormais quoi qu'il arrive nous ne
pouvons plus faire marche arrière
[Musique]
à nos frères et à nos pères qui sont
morts en défendant notre patrie
[Musique]
tu y es pour rien on les boues dans les
régimes en est on
il est temps de se battre c'est une
sacrée arme et qu'on a là
des enfants des déserteurs et des
réfugiés
baïonnette au canon
préparez-vous à monter la sauce
tirailleurs vanak ce présent vous allez
ouvrir la voie aux autres
[Musique]
tout chez eux
bonsecours
tant que je suis pas à la maison la
guerre n'est pas terminée
fin dit cette distinction pour
compétence de dire exceptionnelle
on sera bientôt de retour je t'attendrai
athènes
les déserteurs
on fusille henin
[Musique]
toutes les [ __ ] qui bossent ici
m'appartiennent aussi
et maintenant la tâche n'en
[Musique]
est qu'à sept reprises ses 26 derniers
mois j'ai dû m'asseoir face à des
familles pour livrer le message que leur
fille avait été sauvagement tués jetés
comme un déchet bord de l'autoroute
il y en a une qui sauf
à cet instant
on est dû mais qu'est ce que vous foutez
sur ma scène de crime on avait mis en
place un piège discret ici parce que
j'ai là une pauvre fille de 20 ans avec
6 fracture de la boîte crânienne notre
cible d'hier soir elle a un nom
tu peux pas reprendre la sphère passe à
autre chose personne ne s'est jamais
battu pour ses filles la réaction du
chef est frustrant je ferai cette [ __ ]
d'un filtre si tu veux savoir la vérité
tu finirais par me faire tu
donc nous voilà à l'affût d'un vrai
tueur en série un blanc mâle routier
dans la trentaine c'est qu'il est il a
voulu ligoté une de mes filles ils
rament éclaire sur camion
ils voudraient essayer encore je crois
qu'il m'a repéré je vais lui courir
après
partout les faits
tu m'avais promis ça va pas
je dois faire mon travail
je veux voir des caméras toi
c'est qui
oui vont là où il en est
mais qu'un mentor et va tuer ce soir il
faut que tu fasses absolument tout ce
que tu peux pour sortir de là
dois me promettre de toujours passer
cette porte
police têtards plus un geste
c'est que vous vivez seul je veux
seulement garder un oeil sur vous
je me demande s'il ya quelque chose là
bas
[Musique]
les moments inoubliables de l'enfance
sont des contes de fées
et dans le mien mon père était le prince
cela
au fait chier
on va aller habiter avec papa et des
chaussures voterait peyrecave signoret
[Musique]
comme on va là en amour à ton avis à la
barre il l'a laissé avec 2go ses parents
khénifra c'est juste des amis
je t'aime à gérer tous les deux en est
fait du même bois nos coeurs sont
pareils
papa tu fais quoi
je suis entrepreneur
ton père est un menteur
il faut qu'on se parle franchement tous
les
je veux étudier le journalisme ans
quel genre de genève
l'investigation peut-être
pourquoi avoir menti sur votre
candidature
je suis innocent jusqu'à preuve du
contraire on a décidé que j'avais aucun
droit
votre père john bogle à imprimer 22
millions de dollars
mais si je t'ai tambour d'exploser je
serai là tu ça tes côtés
[Musique]
chaque fois c'est la même histoire elle
est joyeuse quand tu arrives être
bouleversée contours part c'est très dur
boire
puis c'est mon cas je vais travailler
[Musique]
s'est bien passé des lituaniens ouais ça
va ton fils a appelé fait dire notre
fils ah non quand il m'énerve c'est que
le tien
[Musique]
vous embrasse je vous avais tu sais
c'est qu'on travaille fait au téléphone
tu as dit je vous embrasse rajouter quoi
tu joues bien tu
m'expliquer ce que vous faites là bas
j'avais la même question cher marc
gontard et pas que vous connaissez le
coeur sur la patte city
[Musique]
ça fait des choses comme ça saucier de
préparer
du moins permanente à tout le monde tu
me fais peur
il faut appuyer cet excitant une femme
comtois qui vient ici il fait ça ne pas
être effrayé alors que les frais
du marquage
[Musique]
noah chi li na coupe du monde trois
témoins vente m
[Musique]
quel est votre mohammad
question 5
pourquoi vous la vendez toujours retire
une cas
on avait dix neuf mais là je règle tout
en une fois vous savez monsieur qu'à
acheter la can cette nuit là dormi en
bas tous les jours et vient dans les
toilettes me suis dit rien et d'un coup
ils hurlent ils traitent de sales
[ __ ] m j'annule la vente de ces
deux cas vous allez nous rendent les
clichés non la cave elle est à moi vous
avez encaissé le chèque je rentre chez
moi puis voulez vous dit rien
ce type est un négationniste qui nie les
camps de la mort nazis tu m'as jamais
dit qu'on habitait l'appartement ne
tourne que les déportés tu dis rien tu
demande de l'aide à personne on est
frères [ __ ] je sais que j'aurai du
temps parler se font hic c'est un
pervers il va établir son emprise moi je
me contente pas de rabâcher la vérité
officielle je suis un cherche un sens
aux makes you
tu nous promet que tu ne lui parlera
plus
moi c'est fini je mets plus les pieds
dans la gadoue la seule chose qui compte
justin ce que tu as fait nos pensées
pour toi m'at il fait juste que poser
des questions des questions qui
dérangent la vérité officielle vous avez
peur de quoi la vérité
sentir votre peur sait ce qui l'attend
mais simon différent du compte qu'il
aurait pu s'en prendre à être
il semblerait que vous n'êtes pas
propriétaire de votre appartement
comment il me dérange postés
pas pourquoi on s'acharne contre lui oh
tu comprends pas qu'il faut en finir si
vous voulez vraiment prendre les choses
en main tu le cas serait la gueule à
cette pourriture j'étais revenu j'espère
qu
il est seul excellent on est ensemble
linda raclette était non seulement ma
cousine préféré mais elle demeura
pendant des années mon être humain
préféré dumora toujours même si je suis
ennuyeuse
fini je te ravir à jamais de ce
terrifiant droit
mais fillon tout ce dont on a tant
besoin et c'est pourquoi voudrait-elle
s'emballer je veux être libre je veux
m'amuser porter des talons hauts et
aimer à la folie
est-ce qu'il n'y a que l'amour dans la
vie oui
celui qui a inventé l'amour devrait être
abattu
[Musique]
nos débuts tam dans le monde
linda est un fruit mûr pour être
cueillies
et l'arbre venait d'être ce bruit
[Musique]
désire pas un d'amore avoir une vie
aussi excitant
je préfère observer les choses
excitantes
c'est kirk à skull n'ayez pas peur mon
cher matthew nottie et presque
totalement domestiqué tout comme vous
linda est d'une nature si romantique
c'est toujours fatale chez une femme et
moi comment je suis tu es toi fanny tu
t'en sortiras
tu ne peux pas te marier en se basant
sur la romance et l'exaltation si tu ne
te fixe la limite tu n'en aura jamais
assez je ne tiens pas en avoir assez
espérons que les femmes pourront choisir
qui elle se rend indépendamment de qui
elle épouse
avez vous parfois l'impression qu'une
partie de vous êtes des forêts dans une
valise à est en train de suffoquer
pardon
[Musique]
ça vous posera des problèmes
la guerre est inéluctable si perdue sans
toi
pas ici que je me sens chez moi
quoi qu'il arrive je serai toujours de
ton côté
[Musique]